اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه نستعرض نصد معكم ابرز المستجدات
وفي العناوين
هجوم صاروخين روسي من البحر الاسود
واوكرانيا تعلن حاله التاهب القصوى
[تصفيق]
فرنسا تدعو ايران الافراج عن سبعه من
مواطنها وطهران تصف مواقف باريس بغير
الوديه
القوات الاسرائيليه تقتحم مخيمات جنين
للاجئين في الضفه وتقتل اربعه فلسطينيين
اهالي ضحايا انفجار بيروت يعتصمون ضد
اطلاق سراح المتهمين ومعركه قضائيات تهدد
التحقيق
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا البدايه من الهجوم
الصاروخيه الروسي الذي استهدف مدن
اوكرانيه حيث اطلقت اوكرانيا من الغارات
الجويه في جميع انحاء البلاد وطلب
المسؤولون من السكان الاحتمال جيدا بعد
استهداف البنيه التحتيه بضربات صاروخيه
وطائرات مسيره تسببت في انقطاع التيار
الكهربائي عن نطاق واسع وكشف المسؤولون
كبار وكاله رويترز انه احداث الدفاع الجوي
تسقط دفعات الصواريخ الروسيه القادمه في
ما اكد مدير مكتب الرئيس
صواريخ حلقت فوق الاجواء اخونيه من جهته
اعلن حاكم
متجهين الى الشمال الغربي عبر منطقه
مشاهدينا معنا من دونيات مراسل العربيه
رائد الاخبار ومن كيف مراسل العربيه حذيفه
عادل اهلا بكم مع زميلي العزيزين وابدا
معك حذيفه ما مدى عنف هذه الضربات
الصاروخيه الموجهه لمدن الجنوب اوكرانيه
ابتدات من ليله امس طبعا بطائرات شاهد
اطلقت 24 طائره شاهد نحو الاراضي
الاوكرانيه استطاعت القوات الدفاع
الاوكرانيه ان تسقط الطائرات ال 24 جميعا
في الصباح بدات عمليات حالات الانذار
الجوي في عدد كبير من المدن تركز الان
قوات الاتحاد الروسي على الولايات في
الوسط في وسط البلاد وفي غرب البلاد اطلقت
عده صواريخ طبعا كان هنالك ضربه صاروخيه
وكذلك مثلها في مدينه اخر صوت بعد ذلك
اطلقت صواريخ نحو العاصمه الاوكرانيه اكيد
استطاعت قوات الدفاع عن تسقط هذه الصواريخ
بنجاح في العاصمه كيف طبعا عدويه
الانفجارات في العاصمه وبعد ذلك تم
الاعلان عن ان هذا عمل الدفاع الجوي يعني
الاصوات التي سمعت هي كانت عمل الدفاع
الجوي الذي استهدف تلك الصواريخ التي
انطلقت نحو العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف
فينيسيا سمي عدويه الانفجارات مرتين وايضا
بعد ذلك اكد عمده المدينه ان هذا الدفاع
الجوي الذي استطاع ايضا ان يصدر هذه
الصواريخ بنجاح الضربات تركزت في الاوديسه
وجريبروفيروس وميكالايف وفينيسيا واكيف
وجيك كامل والفوف حتى هذه اللحظه تتوقع
تتوقع الدفاع الجوي 30 صاروخا روسيا حتى
هذه اللحظه ولم تطلق طائرات شاهد جديده
بعد تلك التي تم اطلاقها في الصباح وفي
الليل الماضيه نعم رائد هل تاتي هذه
الضربات رد الروسي على الدعم الامريكي
والالماني بالتباريات المتطوره لاوكرانيا
هل صدر من الداخل الروسي ما يؤكد او ينفي
ذلك
احمد يعني الضربات الروسيه لم تتوقف منذ
انطلاق العمليه العسكريه الروسيه والدفاع
الروسيه والمسؤولين
يؤكدونا بان روسيا ستستمر بضرب محطات
انتاج الطاقه
لقطع امدادات مصانع الاسلحه والذخيره من
الكهرباء كما انها تستهدف القواعد
العسكريه حسب المعلومات من الجانب الروسي
همم اذا روسيا تستهدف مناطق ولا تنكر او
يعني تنفي بانها تستهدف المناطق العسكريه
ومحطات انتاج الطاقه لكن المعارك ما زالت
مستعره في جميع المناطق وليس على على صعيد
القصف البعيد هنا في مقاطعه بانيت ما زالت
القوات الروسيه همم يعني تطوق مدينه باخ
مطوه تحاول اقتحامها من الناحيتين
الشماليه والجنوبيه وهناك قتال شوارع في
المناطق الجنوبيه من مدينه باخمت يحاول
الجيش الروسي او قوات باغنا الخاصه اقتحام
المدينه من الناحيه الجنوبيه بعد السيطره
على بلده كلشيفكا والدخول الى بلده
ايفانكا ايضا المحور الجنوبي زبرج- تتقدم
القوات الروسيه وسط تصريحات من قبل
الاداره المعينه من قبل روسيا والمواليه
للروسيه التي تشير الى ان الجيش الاوكراني
حشد اكثر من 40,000 مقاتل للعوده ويعني
اعاده الجيش الروسي من المناطق التي سيطر
عليها في جنوب اوكرانيا بينما يعني هنا
انخفضت وتيره القصف الاوكراني في مدينه
ذلك ل- اا يعني لتصريحات الدفاع الروسيه
بانها تقصف مخازن الذخيره الاوكراني وانها
اصبحت فارغه من الدخيره هناك يعني تطور
ايضا في المحور الصعيده السياسي حيث
تصريحات موسكو بخصوص الدبابات وي يعني
اعلان الغرب تقديم مساعدات همم عسكريه
لجانب الاوكراني قال دمتر مدفيدف نائب
امين عام نائب رئيس المجلس همم رئيس مجلس
الامن الروسي بان روسيا دوله نوويه وعظيمه
ولا يمكن ان تخسر الصراع نعم اعط لك مره
اخرى حذيفه يعني عاطف على الضربات التي
اشرت اليها في مختلف المناطق الاخرانيه هل
صدر من السلطات الصحيه في البلاد اي
احصائيات عن سقوط ضحايا
نعم احمد يعني حتى هذه اللحظه لم يسجل
وصول لضربه صاروخيه منذ الصباح في هذه
الهجمه الاخيره طبعا احمد الان وانا ارقص
هنا لهذا المباشر اسمع اصوات همم انفجارات
في المنطقه يعني لا ادري لا استطيع ان
احدد مكانها بالضبط ولكنها في هذه الجهه
يعني الان انا اسمع اصوات همم يعني اصوات
انفجارات لا استطيع ان احدد اذا كان هذا
الدفاع الجوي يعمل او ان هذا صاروخ روسي
استهدف هذه المنطقه حتى هذه اللحظه كما
اشارت احمد وكما قلت انه لم يسجل وصول
لصاروخ روسي في الهجمات الصباحيه ولكن
الهجمات الليليه كان هناك عدد من الضحك
قاعد استهدفت القوات الروسيه بالامس
بالاراضي الاوكرانيه بعشره الصواريخ
واطلقت سبعه وتسعين ضربه الصواريخ وسبعه
وثلاثين غاره جويه كما اطلقت 24 طائره هذا
هذا في الليله الماضيه الدفاعات الارضيه
حذيفه همم التابع الاوكرانيا بالتاكيد الى
اي ماده تشكل خطرا ايضا على همم حياه
المواطنين لان هناك اصابات في بعض المناطق
جاءت بسبب هذه الدفاعات الارضيه
فقط اذا في عند استهداف الصاروخ الروسي
ينحرف الصاروخ الروسي نفسه عندما يتم
استضافه الصواريخ الاوكرانيه التي تستهدف
هذه الصواريخيه تنطلق من المنطقه التي
تريد حمايتها وتنطلق الى الاعلى فاذا
استهدفت الصاروخ وانحرف الصاروخ عندها
يشكل الخطر لان الخروف يذهب الى مكان الى
غير غير معلوم يعني في مناطق سكنيه وما
الى ذلك اذا شطر الصاروخ او سقطت منه بعض
الشضايا عندها تشكل خطرا فعليه على
المواطنين وطبعا هنا الحديث ليس عن خطر
الدفاع الجوي وانما عن خطر الاستهداف نفسه
همم باي حال من الاحوال صاروخ الدفاع
الجوي يقلل من قطر الصاروخ الذي تم به
الاسلام يعني لن يكون خطره همم
اكبر من خطر ضربه صاروخيه نفسها احمد طيب
رائد اليك مره اخرى همم ما هي الاولويه
بالنسبه للقوات الروسيه وح في ايضا في
مناطق شرق اوكرانيا حاليا
بدايه احمد لا بد من الحديث ان هناك
انعطاف كبيره في يعني مسار المعارك هنا في
الشرق الاوكراني خاصه اعلان روسيا عن دخول
المقاتلات المتطوره الروسيه واسلحه متطوره
نوعيه في نطاق العمليه العسكريه هذا يشير
الى رفع مستوى المعارك والحرب في المناطق
الجنوبيه والشرقيه على حد سواء وتصريحات
امس بدعم الجانب الاوكراني بدبابات متطوره
من امريكا ومن المانيا هذا ايضا يشير الى
رفع مستوى صراع ما بين الطرفين اذن الجانب
الروسي يطور عمليات ونشهد حضور دائم في
سماء المنطقه للمقاتله الروسيات هناك
مناطق يعني تحاول همم تحريرها القوات
الروسيه بغطاء من سلاح الجو مثل منطقه
التي تقع خلف مدينه بيسكو بعد ان سيطر
عليها جيش الروسي وهي ايضا متهاخمه
لمدينتي مارينكا وافديفكا تقاتل القوات
الشيشانيه حصرا في تلك المنطقه بينما هناك
ايضا قوات من افخاذها تقاتل في محاور اخرى
شمال غرب المدينه هناك بالفعل معارك
متطوره ووصول يعني مقاتلين جدد باستمرار
بعد اعلان التعبئه الجزئيه في روسيا
بالفعل اصبحت اعداد المقاتلين اكثر بكثير
في المنطقه وهذا ما يشير الى يعني ما يؤدي
الى تقدم الجيش الروسي حسب النتائج التي
يعني نصفيها بشكل يومي اول مره اخرى اليك
حذيفه السلطات في كيف تقول كمان اشياء في
الخبر العاجل الان اسقطنا جميع الصواريخ
كروز الروسيه التي اطلقت على العاصمه
والتحديد لا يزال قائما هل ما زال تسمع
اصوات الانفجارات حذفت هذه اللحظه
نعم يعني الان وانا اتحدث اليك لا اسمع
صوت الانفجارات قبل دقيقتين فقط او ثلاث
دقائق كنت اسمع هذه الاصوات كما قلت لا
استطيع ان احدد اذا كان هذا عمل الدفاع
الجوي او ان هذا صاروخ روسي سجل وصولا
ولكن بحسب ما افتى الان ان السلطات
الاوكرانيه تقول انه انها اسقطت جميع
الصواريخ فهذا يعني طبعا بالتاكيد ان ما
سمعته قبل قليل كان عمل الدفاع الجوي الذي
ينطلق لاستهداف صاروخ روسي يستهدف العاصمه
اكيد طبعا لا بد ان اقول احمد ايضا ان
شركه الكهرباء اعلنت عن همم قطع الكهرباء
بشكل كامل في العاصمه كيف وفي مدينه
وقائيه احمد لان استهداف المحطات عندما
تكون تعمل يؤدي الى اضرار كبيره
مشاهدينا كشف مسؤول الاوروبي لوكاله
فرانسبريس ان دوله اوروبيه اقترحت ارسال
ذخائر عنقوديه الى اوكرانيه لاعتقادها بان
هذا النوع من الاسلحه قد يساعدك في ساحه
الحرب بحسب قوله وقار المسؤول الذي لم
يرغب في الكشف عن هويته واسمته قال ان
حكومته وافقت على الشحنه حيث كانت تعمل
للحصول على اذن من المانيا التي شاركت في
انتاج هذه الزخائر مشيرا الى ان الذخائر
العنقوديه اصبحت اكثر تقدما وان الغربه
بحاجه ان يكون في موقع متقدم لدعم
اوكرانيا على حد وصفهه هذا وما زالت ورود
الفعل الروسي رسمي تتوالى على قرارات
الغرب بتزويد اوكرانيا بدبابات حديثه حيث
قال رئيس لجنه الدومه للشؤون الدوليه
ليونيل ميسي ان كتيبه الدبابات الامريكيه
لن تساعد زر الاسكي في الاستيلاء على
القرم او تغيير مساعد العمليه الروسيه
الخاصه مضيفا ان جميع الدبابات الامريكيه
او الالمانيه ستصبح اهدافا مشروعه للجيش
الروسي في الوقت ذاته قال رئيس الوفد
الروسي محادثات فيينا حول الامن العسكري
كونستان تين كافي لوف ان موسكو ستعتبره
امداد الدبابات اليوبار بذخيره تحتوي على
ايرانيوم ستعتبره استخدام للقنابل النوويه
القذره
مضيفا ان استخدامها يؤدي الى تلوث المنطقه
كما حدث في غزلافيا والعراق
اعلنت السفاره الامريكيه في روسيا وصول
السفيره الامريكيه الجديده الى موسكو هذا
وكانت لينتريس في سفيره الولايات المتحده
لدى ارمينيا منذ عام 2019 وقبل ذلك كانت
مستشاره لشؤون روسيا في قسم اوروبا
الاسيويه بالخارجيه الامريكيه كما شغلت
منصبه نائب رئيس البعثه في السفاره في
موسكو من عام 2014 الى عام 2017
مستمرا مشاهدينا وفيها بعض الفاصل قوات
كبيره من جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تقتحم
مدينه الجليل ومخيمها واعداد القتلى
الفلسطينيين تواصل الارتفاع
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد وصل رئيس
الوزراء الاثيوبي ابي احمد الى السودان هي
الاولى منذ توتر العلاقات بين البلدين قبل
نحو عامين وفقا لمراسل العربيه بين
الخرطوم في الخرطوم فان ابي احمد سيعقد
نحو خمسه لقاءات مع كل من رئيس المجلس
السيادي عبد الفتاح برهان ونائبه محمد
حمدان اضافه الى مجلس المركزي للحريه
والتغيير والكتله الديمقراطيه والجبهه
الثوريه
لنا يعقوب اهلا بك لينا اذا زياره ابي
احمد الخرطوم تنهي قطيعه استمرت ربما
لاكثر من عامين ايضا صاحبه هذه الفتره ما
الذي حمله ابي احمد
صباح الخير احمد ربا هي دعوه وجهها رئيس
مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان خلال
زيارته الى بحر دار اكتوبر الماضي
الترتيبات جاءت لتعزيز العلاقات الثنائيه
ولكن ابي احمد طلب ايضا ان يلعب دور وسيط
بين الفرقاء السودانيين هذه الزياره
ستناقش اجنده مهمه كانت دائما على طاوله
البلدين مثل الحدود وسط النهضه وغيرها من
القضايا المشتركه ولكن دخلت هذه المره
قضايا الراهن السياسي السوداني في
المباحثات التي ستتم كل هذه المباحثات
احمد ستتم اليوم داخل القصر الجمهوري
سيلتقي كما ذكرت انت قبل قليل بالبرهان
وبنائبه محمد حمدان دلو وايضا بقوه سياسيه
يبدو انها ستتوسع ولن تشمل فقط ثلاثه كتل
رئيسيه هي المجلس المركزي والكتله
الديمقراطيه والجبهه الثوريه انما ايضا
هناك قوه سياسيه اخرى من المقرر ايضا ان
يلتقي بها يبدو ان الجدول اليوم سيكون
مزدحم لابي احمد خلال هذه اللقاءات سيسعى
خلالها الى
احداث ربما توافق جديد بين القوى السياسيه
ونحن نعلم ان هناك كثير من المبادرات
الداخليه والخارجيه التي تحاول ان توفق
بين الاطراف لتوقيع اتفاق نهائي لذلك
وصلوا هو قبل قليل سيدخل في مباحثات اولا
مع البرهان لمناقشه عدد من القضايا وبعد
ذلك نائبه ثم مع بقيه القوى السياسيه
رفض الحريه والتغيير المبادره المصريه
في القاهره لكن اا هل ينظر في هذه الحاله
الى دور تلعبه اثيوبيا في هذا التوقيت
بعين التفاؤل بالنظر الى دورها السابق في
المفاوضات او في الوساطه التي افضت في
النهايه الى توقيع الوثيقه الدستوريه
هناك تفاعل
اثيوبيا هي مثل مثل مصر مثل دول اخرى
لديها علاقه ايضا مع بعض القوى السياسيه
لذلك حينما دخلت مصر
كاوسيط ايضا في هذه الازمه كثير من القوى
السياسيه رحبت وربما تحفظ المجلس المركز
للحريه والتغييره الان همم ابي احمد يلعب
دور ربما ايضا تقبل عدد من القوى السياسيه
وتتحفظ اخرى ولكن يمكن ان اؤكد لك احمد ان
هذه اللقاءات لم يرفض فيها اي قوه او لم
ترفض اي قوه سياسيه ان تلتقي باحمد هي
ستكون اكثر من ثلاثه كتل بحسب ما علمنا
قبل قليل همم تنخرط هذه
الاجتماعات والمباحثات بعد ظهور هذا اليوم
ولكن ما هو غير معلوم حتى اللحظه هل ترتكز
هذه المبادره على الاتفاق الاطاري
همم بين المدنيين والعسكريين والقصد هو
تكمله هذا الاتفاق ام انه ربما يطرح فكره
جديده همم للاطراف السوداني ربما خلال
الساعات المقبله ستتضح الكثير من التفاصيل
شكرا لك من الخرطوم كتب معنا مراسل
العربيه لينا يعقوب تحيه لنا
نبقى في السودان مشاهدينا حيث اكد رئيس
اركان الجيش السوداني الفريق محمد عثمان
الحسين ان الجيش سيقف سدا منيعا امام
الجميع
تاييد القوات المسلحه لاي مساءا سياسي
يخرج البلاد من ازمه السياسيه والاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه
هذه السنه
للتاكيد على جاهزيه القوات المسلحه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تامين لكل حدودنا
تفويدا للفرج على كل المتعامرين
والمتربسين
[موسيقى]
على ان القوات المسلحه
موحده خلف قيادته
تؤيد كل من اساسي يخرج بلادنا من المدرسه
السياسيه
والاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
الى الملف الايراني وفي متابعه ما وصفت
بقضيه دبلوماسيه الرهاء طالب اكثر من 60
عضوا في البرلماني الاوروبي طالب الاتحاد
الاوروبيه باستخدام جميع الوسائل
الدبلوماسيه والسياسيه للافراج عن عام
الاغاثه البلجيكي
اليفيستيل المحتجزي لدى ايران منذ فبراير
الماضي
في اعتقاله غير انسانيه ومروعه وقال
النائب ان فان دي كاستل تم نقله الى مكان
غير معروف لمحامه واقاربه وذلك بعد سجنه
وتعذيبه في سجن ايفان بطهران وكانت
الحكومه بلجيكيه اعتبرت ان ظروف عند
كريستيانو
رونالدو الايراني
بمواقفه باريس غير الوديه حسب وصفه وجاء
ذلك خلال اتصال هاتفي لبحث العلاقات
الثنائيه بين باريس
وكاله الانباء الطلبه ايرانيه اسنا قالت
ان السلطات القضائيه الايرانيه ذكرت ان
نحو 40 من الرعايه الاجانب سجن ومن بينهم
سبعه فرنسيين بتهمه التحريض على احتجاجات
في مختلف انحاء البلاد
والاحتجاجات في الداخل الايراني وقمع
النظام المحتجين حيث اشار الصحيفه واشنطن
في وسط الامريكيه الى ان سبعه قضاه
ايرانيين اصدروا ما لا يقل عن 17 حكما
بالاعدام في الاسابيع الاخيره بعضهم من
المحكمه العليا الايرانيه وذكر التقدير
اسماء عدد من القضاه وهم ابو القاسم
سلافاتي ومحمد رضا اموزاد وهادي منصور
وعالم مظلوم ايضا
افضل مشاهدينا وكان القاضي ابو القاسم
سلافات الملقب بقاضي الموت قد وضع تحت
العقوب الامريكيه عام 2019 فيما طالت
اخرين عقوبات بريطانيه في ديسمبر الماضيه
في الوقت ذاته اوضح التقدير ان هؤلاء
الخضار قد يواصلون النظر في قضايا اخرى
وان احكام الاعدام الصادر عنهم واجهها
بعضها نقدا في الاستئناف
تعرضت لوحه تكرم ذكرى اقامه الخميني في
فرنسا اواخر السبعينيات للتخريب وافاده
الشرطه الفرنسيه افادت بان لوحه المثبته
على ارض خاصه في بلده نوفل لو تشاد شاتو
قرب باريس حطمت والقيت على الارض ويتزامل
ذلك مع تواصل احتجاجات المناهضه لنظام في
جميع انحاء ايران الى جانب فرض عقوبات
دوليه على كيانات وشخصيات داخل النظام
الايراني بسبب قمع الاحتجاجات واحكام
اعدام بحق المحتاجين
والى ملف التهديدات النوويه الايرانيه حيث
قال صحيفه فينشيال تايمز في تقرير ان
الغرب يواجهم معضله بشان المحادثات
النوويه الايرانيه مشيره الى انه حتى في
ظل وصول العلاقات الى مستويات متدنيه الا
ان المسؤولين الامريكيين والاوروبيين
يبقون باب الدبلوماسيه مفتوحا امام ايران
الصحفيه بل الصحيفه ارجع ذلك الى انه على
الرغم من عدم تفاؤل الغربي بحدوث انفراجه
قريبه الا ان ذلك يعكس حجم الماضيه التي
تواجهها القوه الغربيه في ظل خياراتها
المحدوده لمنع ايران من توسيع برنامجها
النووي
اربعه قتلى وعدد كبير من الجرح
الفلسطينيين على يد القوات الاسرائيليه في
الاشتباكات العنيفه التي شهدها مخيم جنين
قبل الساعات وزاره الصحه
في المخيم بانه خارج للغايه وكشفت مصادر
امنيه لوكاله الانباء الفلسطينيه بان
القوات الاسرائيليه اقتحمت مدينه
اسطح المنازل في المخيم بحثا عن مطلوبيننا
الجيش الاسرائيلي
الجنود الرصاصه
وكيفيه المصادر ان القوات الاسرائيليه
قطعت التيار الكهربائي عن المخيم ومنع
الطواقيم الاسعاف والصحفينا من دخوله
يحدث هذا فيما اقدمت جرافه الاسرائيلي على
تحطيم مركبات واجهات مع حاله تجاريه
بالقرب من مستشفى جنين الحكمي شمال الضفه
الغربيه هذا هو يعج مستشفى جنين بالمرضى
معظمهم من الاطفال الذين اصيبوا بالاختناق
نتيجه اطلاق القوات الاسرائيليه قنابل
الغاز اتجاه المستشفى كما اظهر فيديو اخر
انتشال احد الضحيتين بل احد الضحايا من
المخيم بعد اقتحامه من قبل الجيش
الاسرائيلي
مشاهدينا من رام الله ينظم
سوء الوضع الان في مخيم جنين
نعمل وضع سيء للغايه وفقه وصفه وزاره
الصحه الفلسطينيه وفق الصور والمشاهد التي
تصلنا اتباعا من مدينه جنين العمليه
العسكريه الاسرائيليه مستمره منذ نحو اربع
ساعات وما زالت هناك اشتباكات عنيفه تدور
بين مقاتلين فلسطينيين وبين قوات كبيره من
الجيش الاسرائيلي التي اقتحمت المخيم وبين
عدد ايضا من القناص الذين يعتلون المباني
العاليه في المخيم ومحيط المخيم ويقومون
باستهداف لمقاتلين الفلسطينيين او حتى
للمواطنين العاديين الان ضروره انهار
والعمليه بدات مع ذره المدارس وبالتالي
هناك مواجهات بين عدد كبير من طلبه
المدارس الفلسطينيه الذين لم يتوجهوا الى
مدارسهم في جنين وانما توجه الى نقاط
المواجهه وفك وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه
عدد الضحايا حتى هذه اللحظه اربعه منهم
سيده فلسطينيه اصيبت برصاصه قناص في العنق
وايضا هناك ثلاثه عشر جريحا
عفوا منهم ثلاث اصابات خطيره ولكن وفق
ايضا بعد المصادر داخل المخيم ربما عدد
ضحايا الضعف هذا الرقم وذلك نظرا لاستمرار
القوات الاسرائيليه بمنع دخول سيارات
الاسعاف الى داخل المخيم وانتشار الضحايا
من داخل المخيم
الاشتباكات متواصله هناك الجرافات
اسرائيليه داخل المخيم قامت بهدم نادي
جنين بالكامل وتدمير بعض المركبات اضافه
الى بعض الشوارع والطرقات في محيط مستشفى
جنين لتسهيل دخول وخروج القوات
الاسرائيليه من هناك طيب لكلفهم الصوره
كامل عبد الحفيظ يعني ما الذي استدعاء
قيام السلطه الاسرائيليه باقتحام هذا
المخيم في هذا التوقيت
نعم هناك عمليات عسكريه اسرائيليه متواصله
سواء في جنين او بقيه المدن الفلسطينيه
للاعتقال المطلوبين او ما تسميهم قوات
الاسرائيليه بمطلوبين وبالتالي العمليه
صباح هذا اليوم بدات بمحاوله قوات خاصه
بالدخول بشاحنه حليب الى داخل المخيم جنين
لتنفيذ اعتقال ما تقول اسرائيل انه مطلوب
كبير داخل المخيم لكن يظهر انهم كشف امر
هذه القوه الخاصه في الشاحنه المدنيه
وبالتالي عدد من المقاتلين قاموا باطلاق
النار على هذه الشاحنه ما استدعى طلب
تعزيزات كبيره دخلت محاور مختلفه الى
مدينه جنين وتحولت عمليه الاعتقال الى هذا
المشهد المتواصل منذ اربع ساعات اشتباكات
عنيفه همم اطلاق صواريخ من الجانب
الاسرائيلي صواريخ محموله على الكتف على
بعض البنايات وايضا يرد المقاتلون باطلاق
الرصاص وبعض القنابل يدويه الصنع عمليا
لهذه العمليه الاطول والاكبر منذ يعني
اشهر طويله لان نشهد مثل هذه العمليه همم
عدد في جنين منذ بدايه اصلا منذ بدايه هذا
العام في الشهر الاول من هذا العام وصل
الى 13 وقد يرتفع جنيه المستهدفه بشكل
كبير نظرا لوجود عدد من الخلايا المسلحه
النشطه داخل المخيم جنين طيب قد يكون كل
ذلك او بعد ذلك مفهوم لكن ما علاقه مستشفى
جنين الحكومي حتى يستهدف به الغازات
المسيئه للدموع
مع مستشفى جنين الحكومي يقع بجوار تماما
بجوار المخيم عدد كبير من الجرحه نقل الى
مستشفى الجنين الى الحكومي الى ايضا عدد
كبير من الضحايا الى المستشفى اضافه الى
المستشفى همم ابن سينا وبالتالي عدد كبير
من المواطنين هرعوا الى المستشفى
للاطمئنان على ذويهم وابنائهم من توجهوا
الى المدارس همم قوات الاسرائيليه قامت
بمحاوله وحدثت مواجهات قريبا من المستشفى
وبالتالي القوات الاسرائيلي قامت باطلاق
لاعيرا ناريه وقناه بالغاز الى داخل
المستشفى ما ادى الى اصابه عدد كبير من
الاطفال وخصوصا يعني الغازات دخلت الى قسم
الاطفال داخل المستشفى نعم والله كنت معنا
مراسل العربيه
مشاهدينا الان نتابع هذه الصور التي وصلت
في قناه العربيه من داخل مستشفى جنين
الحكومي الذي تعرض لاطلاق الغازات المسيئه
للدموع ما فاقمها الاصابات
والحالات الاختناق في داخل هذا المستشفى
كل ذلك مشاهدينا ياتي في سياق قيام الجيش
الاسرائيلي باسم مصطفى هذا اليوم باقتحام
مدينه ومخيم جنين مادى حتى هذه اللحظه الى
السقوط عدد من الجرحى وايضا سقوط اربعه
قتلى بحسب وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه حتى هذه
اللحظه
اطفال اطفال
عن الرئاسه الفرنسيه ان اللقاء ياتي بعد
دعوه للسوداني وكان الطرفان قد طراسان
مؤتمر الدوليه بغداد اثنين لدعم العراق
باستضافه من الاردن نهايه العام الماضي
واضاف بيان الرئاسه الفرنسيه ان اللقاء
سيوفر فرصه لترتيب النسخه الثانيه من
مؤتمر بغداد 2 للتعاون والشراكه الاقليميه
الى جانبي بحث سبل القضائي على الارهاب
في العراق ايضا انطلق تظاهره نظامها
ناشطون صباحا امس بالقرب من مبنى البنك
المركزي في العاصمه العراقيه بغداد
مطالبين بايقاف تهريب العمله وخفض سعر صرف
الدولار امام الدينار التفاصيل مع سامر
الكبيسي
[تصفيق]
بالقرب من مبنى البنك المركزي قادمينا من
محافظات بابل والنجف وحتى بغداد
والمحافظات الجنوبيه مطالبين بخفض سعر صرف
الدولار والذي وصل الى بدايات القياسيه
راديتونا بلقمه العيش هؤلاء العراقيين الى
ماجد جاءوا من مختلف مناطق العراق من وسطه
من جنوبه
يطالبون بمطالب شرعيه منها خفض سعر
الدولار الذي اصبح كاهل على الشعب العراقي
بعدما كان 120 118 صعد الى 150 بمقابل
الدولار العمله الاجنبيه وبعدين صعد الى
160 167 ربما 170
[موسيقى]
مطالب المتظاهرين تنوعت بين ايقاف في
تهريب العمله ومحاسبه المضاربين داخل
الاسواق الماليه
يضاف لها عقد جلسه طارئه لمجلس النواب
لمناقشه ارتفاع سعر صرف الدولار امام
الدينار انهيار الدينار العراقي ما معنى
انهيار الدوله والسبب الاساسي لكل هذا هو
تهريب العمله الثانيه يجب ان تكون الحكومه
الامريكي لجود حل هذه المساله
يعني اول شيء احنا كل الدول
[موسيقى]
كماهره انتهت بشكل سلبي بالاتفاق بين
القوات الامنيه والمتظاهرين لكن
المتظاهرين هددوا في حال لم يتم الاستجابه
لهذه المطالب بتظاهرات اكبر وربما حتى
اوسع في بغداد والمحافظات
بشارع الرشيدي في بغداد سامر الكبيسي
العربيه
[تصفيق]
النزاهه في العراق
مخالفات الماليه قانونيه بحق الدوله وذكر
بيان هيئه النزاهه العراقيه انا الوزير
السابق عندما كشفا غير مطابق للحقيقه
وعرضه على مجلس الوزراء بهذا الاسم
الدوله كما اكد البيان ان محكمه الجنايات
مكافحه الفساد المركزيه اصدرت امر
الاستقدام بحق الوزير السابق فضلا عن
ثلاثه محافظين لبابل لقيامهم بتخصص قطاع
اراضي تجاريه خلافا لقرار مجلس الوزراء
اعراب اسكان وجهاء وعشائر في الرقه اكبر
مدينه عربيه شرق سوريا
وهو ما لا يمكن قبله
لا للتعويني او التطبيع جمل يتفق عليها
اغلب سكان الرقه ووجهه وعشائرها الى جانب
الادارتين العسكريه والمدنيه في رفض واضح
للتقارب بين النظام السوري وتركيا تركيا
تركيا
ويرى وجهاء وعشائر ان تركيا تستخدم ورقه
التطبيع مع الاسد لاهداف انتخابيه خالصه
على حساب معاناه السوريين
وجراحهم التي لم تندمل بعد
على اي اساسي الى 16 مليون من الشعب
السوري خارج
البيوت
اللاجئين في اوروبا بالانتخابات
وتخشى المدينه من ان تقود اي اتفاقيات
مستقبليه الى عوده النظام للانتقام من
السكان تحت دراعه كثيره او جلب ايران
واطلاق يدها على غرار ما يحدث في دير
الزور القريبه
مرفوض هنا سواء من قبل تركيا واي دوله
اخرى لان ذلك سيمحم مسؤوليته عن قتل
السوريين وتدمير البلاد وفقا للسكان من
مدينه الرقه شمال شرق سوريا جمعه كاش
العربيه
مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل
مسؤولون الكبار في الامم المتحده يستعون
الى تخفيف قيود طالبان على النساء في
افغانستان
هجوم صارخي روسي من البحر الاسود
واوكرانيا تعلن حاله التاهب القصوى
فرنسا تدعو ايران للافراج عن سبعه من
مواطنها وطهران تصف مواقف باريس
القوات الاسرائيليه تقتحم مخيمه جليل
اللاجئين في الضفه وتقتل اربعه فلسطينيين
اهالي ضحايا انفجار بيروت يعتصمون ضد
اطلاق سراح المتهمين ومعركه القضائيه تهدد
التحقيق
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من
جديدان رفيعان طالبان على ابداع مزيد من
الوضوح بشان انقطاعات الانسانيه التي يمكن
اعاده فتحها امام الموظفات والافغانيات مع
تحذير احدهما من ان ماجاعه تلح في الافق
خلال فصل الشتاء القصير
ضغط الامم يعلى طلبان بشان عمل الافغانيات
مسؤولان اماميان حدا طالبان بشان القطاعات
الانسانيه التي يمكن اعاده فتحها امام
الموظفات الافغانيه
افغانستان وفي بعض الاحيان لم يكن رد
الفعل لطيفا
امين محمد نائبه الامين العام للامم
المتحده
وكالات الاغاثه اعلنت ان افغانستان تواجه
واحده من اسوء الازمات الانسانيه في
العالم اذ يهدد الجوع اكثر من نصف سكانها
الوكالات اشارت الى ان الازمه تتفاقمت
عندما منع الطالبان النساء الافغانيات من
العمل في المنظمات غير الحكوميه طالبان
عادت وسمحت في الاسابيع الاخيره للنساء
بالعمل في المنظمات الصحيه
[موسيقى]
في اعاده فتح المزيد من القطاعات
الانسانيه امام الموظفات الافغانيه
بينما بيوم التعليم
وذلك بتحويل المدارس الى تقنيه العسكريه
ومنابر للتعبئه الطائفيه
يسكن المعلم ومربي الاجيال علي الوليدي
بمحافظه في مقربه بعد نجاته من قبضه
الحوثيين في مديريه الحيمه غربيه العاصمه
صنعاء حاله غيره من المعلمين اليمنيين
الذين استهدفتهم الميليشيات الحوثيه في
اطار استهدافها للعمليه التعليميه بشكل
عام قتلوا معظم المعلمين
وادخلهم الى الحبس حبسهم
وشردوهم وقطعوا رواتبهم هذا الاضرار التي
لحقت المعلم من قبل الحوثيين ثم المنهج
نفسه غيره بدل ما كان منهج الوطني يغيره
بالمنهج وافكار طائفيه يحتفل العالم بيوم
التعليم وقد تحولت مئات المدارس في اليمن
منذ سيطره الحوثيين على العاصمه صنعاء الى
سكنات عسكريه وصارت مخرجات التعليم
الملغمه بافكار العنف والطائفيه والعنصريه
تساقط الى الموت في جبهات القتال الطالب
نفسه ياخذونهم من المدارس الى همم عمليه
غسيل الدماء في المراكز حقهم ثم اخذ لهم
الى الجبهه ويعملوا لهم شهائد في الجبهات
بل شهائد جامعي مش اللي همم تعليم الثانوي
الاعدادي شهايد جامعي وهم في الجبهه
فدمروا العمليه التعليميه واصبح اليمن عاد
عشرات السنين الى الوراء بمناهج محرفه
وبلا مرتبات يجبر المعلمون تحت سطوه
الحوثيين اداء عمليه تعليميه شكليه والى
مناطق سيطره الشرعيه فرك كثير منهم لتحصين
ابنائهم والتدريس هناك للحصول على مرتبه
يعول اسرهم
اضطرينا نمزح من بلادنا همم حيث انه لا
يوجد مرتب وكذلك حفاظ على ابنائنا من
التعليم على ابناء المواصلات التعليم
الكبار والصغار حتى
يكملوا تعليم
الدول بتطوير التعليم ومخرجاته وتتراجع
العمليه التعليميه في اليمن عقودا الى
الخلف ضمن السياسه التجه التي تمارسها
الميليشيات الحوثيه
تسود حاله من الغضب في صفوف اهالي ضحايا
المرفا بعد قرار القاضي غسان عويدات اطلاق
سراح جميع الموقوفين بقضيه المرفى لمن
فيهم بدر ظاهر ويحضر اهالي تحرك اليوم
بالتزامني مع انعقاد مجلس القضاء الاعلى
لمناقشه التطورات قضيه تجاري مرفق بيروت
طارق البيطار حربه القضائيه
[موسيقى]
لكن الرد التمدويا من مدعي عام التمييز
غسان عويدات بالافراج عن موقفينا مده
عليهم في قضيه انفجار مرفا بيروت
قرار اصاب الشادي بجرح لا يقل الما عن ما
الشعر به عندما راى شقيقه مرميا في الرابع
من اغسطس
ليفجع اليوم مره ثانيه مترحما على قضاء
غدر بقدرهم كما يقول
مرتين انا كنت اساس هي عندي امل بالدوله
اللبنانيه بس طلع ما في امل لا الدوله
اللبنانيه ولا بالقضاء القضاء طلع اهل
الشهداء والقضاء علينا ولا عدل ولا عداله
فيها هذه البلد انا بطلب من القاضي عوادات
يرجع ضميره
يرجع ضميره نحنا اخواتنا
عم تخلي سبيل موقوفين هي حرب القضاء اذا
لا يحبذها اهل القانون لكن خارج القضبان
بات بدري ضهر حرا هو مدير عام الجمارك
السابق الذي قاد التيار الوطني الحر حمله
شرسه لاطلاقه اما من افرج عنه فهو غسان
عويدات القاضي الذي كفت يده عن القضيه
بسبب علاقه المصاهره التي تربطه
نائب حركتي امل الذي شن الثنائي الشيعي
حربا لمنع موسوله امام القاضي البيطار
صلاحيته بشكل
هلا بالنص
بيعرف
بس ولكن
التي لم تستثني الشارع كسبيلا للتعبير عن
غضبهم غدا انفجار بيروت على اكثر من 200
ضحيه لبنانيه اما قرار القضاء بالافراج عن
الموقوفين فقضى على قلوب اهالا كانت تعيش
على امل تحقيق العداله غنوه يتيم العربيه
بيروت
وتبقى معنا مشاهدينا من بيروت مراسله
العربيه
وهل بدات الوقفه الاحتجاجيه
المنظمه اليوم وما هي ابرز الشعارات
المرفوعه في هذا الاحتجاج
يعني
وصل ايضا عدد من نواب التغيير الذين
يريدون طبعا دعم الاهالي هنا معنى النائب
جورج عويس
اليوم معارضه اجتمعتوا على هذه القضيه شو
الخطوات اللي راح تطلب فيها تزامنا المجلس
الاعلى
مع السلطه السياسيه استباحه القضاء
السباحه العذريه تنفذ السياسي مع الاسف في
ينفذها الى همم بعض القضاه وبعد المراجع
القضائيه اللي عم تستولى على ملف خارج
صلاحيتها عم تاخذ قرارات لا يسمح القانون
لها باتخاذها نحنا مع الناس ومع اهل
الضحايا اه نقف اولا تحرير هذا التحقيق
العدل لكي يصل الى نتيجه نهائيه لانه في
جريمه صارت بدنا تعويض عنها في جريمه صارت
بدنا كشف الحقيقه عنا في قرار التهامي يجب
ان يصدر عن هذا المحقق لعيانته الحكومي
القرار الاتيمي يحال الى المجلس العدلي
وينقد وتكون المحاكميه امام وعلنيه ويصدر
حكم نهائي هذا لبدنيه بدنا مسار طبيعي مثل
كل دول العالم مع الاسف في اصرار على
عرقله هذا التحقيق في اسرار على الموبره
ضد اراده اهالي ضحايا ضد اراده اظهار
الحقيقه في لبنان وهذا اللي احنا عملنا
معها او لا اله الا الله
يعني نقدر نوصل مع حكمه رئيس مجلس القضاء
الاعلى
ملقى عليه بيفتكر رسوليه تاريخيه اليوم
على الاقل بانه يقلب الطاوله على رؤوس
الجميع كل اللي عم بيعطلوا القضاء من داخل
القضاء ومن خارج القضاء ويقول كلمه مدويه
بوجهها
نحنا بازارته اليوم بمؤازره الضحايا وادي
مواجهه مفتوحه مع هذه شكرا
ان اذكر فقط بان مجلس الاعلى للقضاء ينعقد
اليوم هو من سبعه اعضاء يمكن في حال يعني
التصويت يجب ان يكون من خمسه اعضاء لذلك
يعني في حال لم يكن التصويت بالاجماع لن
يصل المجلس الى اي قرار ان يشقى المجلس
ينعقد اليوم بعد التطورات القضائيه
الاخيره التي حدثت همم بين القاضي طارق
بين القاضي طارق همم البيطار ومدعي عام
التمييز والبعض وصفها بان حرب قضائيه
البعض يقول بان اليوم طارق البيطار يقف
وحيدا الى جانب اهالي الضحايا لذلك كانت
هذه الوقفه من نواب المعارضه ان كان تغيير
او قوات او كتائب الى جانب اهالي الضحايا
امام قصر العدل طيب
هناك مطالبات بتدوير هذه القضيه واللجوء
الى تحقيق امنيين او تحقيق دولي هل ما زال
هذه الدعوات صدى في الداخل اللبناني حتى
الان
بالطبع هذه الدعوات لا زالت قائمه بعد ان
نواب يطالبون ايضا بتدوير القضيه لانهم
يرون بان القضاء اللبناني قد لا يتمكن من
الوصول الى اي حال في موضوع انفجار بيروت
لانه حتى لو كان هناك
قضاء نزيه او بعض القضاه الذين يبتسمون
بالنزاهه ولكن هناك تدخلات سياسيه في هذا
القضاء ايضا اهالي الضحايا الذين كان كان
يشعرون بغضب كبير يوم امس على موضوع اخلاء
سبيل جماعي للموقفين يقولون بان الحل
الوحيد ربما هو تدوين هذه القضيه خاصه ان
بين الضحايا كان هناك ضحايا اجانب نحن
نعلم ان القضاء الفرنسي كان يتابع هذه
القضيه لانه كان يوجد فرنسيين بين الضحايا
وكانك الطلبه القضاء ببعض المعلومات
القضاء اللبناني وتاخر القضاء اللبناني به
اعطاء هذه المعلومات
اللبناني بشده وهو ايضا همم هناك مطالبه
له خصنا من غسان عويدات بالاستقال هل هناك
من مؤشرات على انه قد يقبل او يخضع لهذه
الاقتراح
البدعه غسان عويدات كان قد صرح يوم امس
بانهم بانهم لن يعني يزيلوا على القاضي
طارق البيطار عن هذه القضيه ولكن هناك
يعني تحديد لمسار تطورات التي حدثت خاصه
وان من وجهه نظر قضائيه همم من وجهه نظر
قضائيه
القاضيان ربما لم يقوم به الصالحيات
المناطه لهم بانهم يعني اتخذوا اجراءات
غير همم ليست من صلاحياتهم ضمن القانون
ولكن هذا ال- همم التحقيق هو متوقف منذ
اكثر من عام 14 هناك معلومات تشير بان
القاضي طارق البيطار كان يعلم بانه هناك
همم قرار سيدتخذ باخلاء سبيل جميع
الموقوفين لذلك كانت لهذه الدراسه
القانونيه التي قام بها واعاد نفسه الى
تحقيق الذي كانت قصه يده عنه يعني فعلا
فعلا القضيه همم
طيب القضائيه والبرلمان وايضا مع الاجهزه
الامنيه اعتذر منك غنوه هذا ما سمح به
الوقت شكرا لك من بيروت كنت معنا مؤسسه
العربيه غنويتين تحياتي
مشاهدينا اعوذتي السلطات الصينيه تراجعوا
الوفيات اليوميه الناتجه عن فيروس كورونا
بنحوي 80% منذ بدايه الشهر الحالي
واشتتاحت اكبر دوله في العالم من حيث عدد
السكان موجه اصابات واسعه النطاق بفيروس
كورونا منذ ان اوقفت بكين بشكل مفاجئ
سياسه السفر وما يترتب عليها من اجراءات
صارمه
قال ان تطبيقات التواصل الاجتماعي التابعه
لشركه
الى العمل بعد فتره تعطل قصيره في
الولايات المتحده امس الاربعاء واشار
الموقع الى ان ثمانيه
عن مواجهتهم مشاكل في تطبيق انستغرام في
الولايات المتحده فيما فيما تم رصد اكثر
من ثلاثه عشر الف واقعه لتعطل تطبيق
فيسبوك فضلا عن تقرير عن اعطاني في تطبيق
واتساب وفيسبوك ماسنجر في الوقت نفسه
تقريبا وفقا لموقعي داون لدكتور
ولا مشاهدينا الى العناوين
هجوم صاروخين روسي من البحر الاسود
واوكرانيا تعلن حاله التاهب القصوى
فرنسا تدعو ايران الافراج عن سبعه من
مواطنها وطهران تصف مواقف باريس بغير
الوديه
القوات الاسرائيليه تقتحم مخيم جنين
للاجئين في الضفه وتقتل ثمانيه فلسطينيه
اهالي ضحايا انفجاري مرفا بيروت يعتصمون
ضد اطلاق سراح المتهمين ومعركه قضائيه
تهدد التحقيق
مشاهدينا نهايه هذه الساعه الاخباريه شكرا
لحسب متابعه والمزيد يمكنكم الانتقال الى
موقع العربيه مشاهدينا
[موسيقى]